>> WELL EARLIER TODAY, THE HEAD
OF THE WAGNER GROUP, YEVGENY
PRIGOZHIN CLAIMED THAT THE
ENTIRE AREA AROUND SOLEDAR IS
UNDER RUSSIAN CONTROL.
UKRAINE DENIES THIS, AND THE
KREMLIN WILL ONLY SAY THAT
THERE IS A POSITIVE TREND IN
THE FIGHTING.
MY NEXT GUEST TWEETED ABOUT A
PROPOSAL BY A REPORTER FROM
RUSSIAN STATE MEDIA THAT, QUOTE,
YEVGENY PROVISION IT WILL BE
PROMOTED TO MAJOR GENERAL.
THESE SOLEDAR OFFENSIVE WILL
BOLSTER HIS STANDING IN RUSSIAN
POLITICS.
SAMUEL RAHMANI JOINS ME NOW
FROM OXFORD IN ENGLAND.
CAN YOU JUST EXPLAIN FOR OUR
VIEWERS, WHO THE WAGNER GROUP
IS FIRST AND FOREMOST?
AND WHO IT IS WHO RUNS IT.
>> SO THE WAGNER GROUP IS
NOMINALLY A PRIVATE COMPANY.
THAT IS ILLEGAL UNDER RUSSIAN
LAW.
IT IS CLOSELY ALIGNED WITH THE
MAIN INTELLIGENCE DIRECTORATE.
THE HEAD OF THE WAGNER GROUP'S
YEVGENY PRIGOZHIN.
>> WHAT DOES THE KREMLIN GAIN
FROM HAVING HIM AND THE WAGNER
GROUP WORKING FOR THEM,
EFFECTIVELY?
AND WHAT DO THEY GAIN FROM
WAGNER MERCENARY ACTIVITIES ON
THE GROUND IN UKRAINE?
LET'S BE QUITE CLEAR ABOUT
THIS.
>> WELL, THE WAGNER GROUP,
FIRST OF ALL, ADDS MAN COUNT OF
RUSSIAN MILITARY.
40,000 CONSCRIPTS FROM THE
PRISONS, BEFORE THAT MAJOR
MOBILIZATION.
ALSO, THEY ARE TRAINED AND HAVE
EXPERIENCE.
ALSO THE WAGNER GROUP IS ADEPT
AT SEIZING CONTROL OF MINERAL
ASSETS IN THESE INFORMATION
CAMPAIGNS.
THEY HAVE CONTROL OF THIS TOWN,
WHICH IS VERY CLOSE TO BAKHMUT.
WE'VE BEEN EXPLAINING WHY THAT
IS SIGNIFICANT.
WHAT I DID THINK WAS IMPORTANT
WAS THAT YESTERDAY, THEY
SUGGESTED THAT THE UKRAINIANS
HAVE BEEN FIGHTING WITH HONOR.
IT DID SEEM ODD, COMING FROM A
MAN WHOSE REPUTATION STANDS
BEFORE HIM, AS IT WERE.
WAGNER'S AMBITIONS HAVE NOT
GONE UNNOTICED IN WASHINGTON
D.C..
TAKE A LISTEN TO WHAT THE
SECRETARY OF DEFENSE SAID AT A
BRIEFING A FEW DAYS AGO.
>> IN THE RECENT PAST, WE'VE
SEEN THAT WAGNER IS ADVANCING
AND A MORE RAPID CLIP THAT ANY
OTHER UNIT IN THE RUSSIAN
MILITARY.
>> CRACK STARTING TO EMERGE IN
WAGNER'S RELATIONSHIP,
CERTAINLY WITH THE OTHER
RUSSIAN MILITARY.
ARE WE SEEING CRACKS WITH THE
KREMLIN?
PARTICULARLY THE RUSSIAN
DEFENSE MINISTER SHOW A GO.
AND IF SO, WHAT COMES NEXT?
WHAT'S THE END GOAL HERE FOR
WAGNER?
>> SO YEVGENY PRIGOZHIN HAS HAD
A LONG-STANDING NEGATIVE
RELATIONSHIP WITH --
IT DATES BACK TO THE CAMPAIGN
IN SYRIA WHEN THE WAGNER GROUP
WAS OFTEN DIRECTLY BEING HIRED
BY THE RUSSIAN DEFENSE MINISTRY,
TO CARRY OUT OPERATIONS.
AND NOW, WITH YEVGENY PRIGOZHIN
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF HOW THIS
WAR IS BEING PROSECUTED, HAS HE
USED TELEGRAM CHANNELS TO SMEAR
--
SO IT APPEARS AS IF YEVGENY
PRIGOZHIN IT'S TRYING TO
POSITION SELF AS A SHADOW
DEFENSE MINISTER OF SORTS, WHO
IS MORE RESPECTED THAN --
AND ALSO WHO HAS PUTIN'S EAR.
SO I THINK THAT THIS IS
SIGNIFICANT REALIGNMENT OF
RUSSIAN ELITE POLITICS, THAT
COULD MAKE RUSSIA EVEN MORE
UNPREDICTABLE AND DANGEROUS,
AND MORE RESISTANT TO DIPLOMACY
AND COOPERATION.
>> IT'S GOOD TO GET YOUR
ANALYSIS, IT'S AN IMPORTANT
STORY.
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT STORY, ON
THE GROUND.
WE ARE TEN AND A HALF MONTHS
INTO THIS CONFLICT, AND WE HAVE
SEEN SOME OF THE MOST BRUTAL
TRENCH WARFARE AROUND SOLEDAR
AS THAT BATTLE CONTINUES.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE GET THE
CONTEXT FROM THAT BATTLE FOR SO
WHAT ARE.
THANK YOU FOR PUTTING A
SPOTLIGHT ON THE WAGNER GROUP,
AND CNN TAKES A LOOK AT THE
CONTROVERSIAL LEADER.
FIND OUT WHY HE IS CALLED
PUTIN'S CHEF, AND WHY HE'S USED
THE WAR IN UKRAINE TO RAISE
WAGNER'S PROFILE.
THAT'S ALL ON YOUR CNN APP.
YOU CAN LOG IN AT CNN.COM.